des cas de jeunes migrants dans la rue
mineur en attente de prise en charge
d'autres déclarés majeurs par le
Département
Utopia 56 les recueils mais manquent de
place et de bras une cinquantaine de
bénévoles de l'association manifestait
aujourd'hui à Tours
[Musique]
Yusuf est originaire de Guinée il a 16
ans et demi et est arrivé à Tours il y a
4 mois et épaulé par l'association
Utopia 56 il va à l'école alternative en
attendant d'être scolarisé ou de
travailler mais reste pour le moment
sans papiers
avec mes papiers mes documents au
département mais ils m'ont dit que les
documents étaient
authentifiés soi-disant je sais pas que
c'était quoi sinon je suis venu avec ma
carte d'identité scolaire tout bon voilà
quand j'ai dit ça ils m'ont dit que non
que ce n'est pas ça depuis 2017 50% des
jeunes accompagnés par Utopia 56 ont été
reconnus mineurs par un juge des enfants
ils sont ensuite pris en charge par
l'aide sociale à l'enfance mais chaque
année l'association recueille de
nouveaux migrants et elle se sentent
abandonnées par les pouvoirs publics ça
fait cinq ans qu'on demande à ce qui
nous rencontrent pour discuter de ces
jeunes qui sont refusés par le
département pour qu'on puisse trouver
des solution entre l'État le département
la mairie toutes les institutions et le
président du Département bloque
complètement en un mois
dit je t'ai remis à la rue faute de
papier en règle de son côté le
département d'Indre-et-Loire n'a pas
donné suite à notre demande d'interview